>>> HOW MANY WAYS ARE THERE TO
SIT ON THE TOILET?
>> THERE'S ONLY ONE ACCEPTABLE
WAY TO SIT ON THE TOILET.
>> ONE WAY.
>> ONE MUST SIT UPRIGHT.
>> NO SLOUCHING!
BACK STRAIGHT.
>> FEET SHOULD BE PLANTED FIRMLY
ON THE FLOOR.
>> AND WHAT SHOULD SITTING ON
THE TOILET NEVER BE?
>> COMFORTABLE OR RELAXING.
>> CORRECT.
THAT IS THE NUMBER ONE RULE.
AND RULES ARE MEANT TO BE.
>> BROKEN!
>> WHO ARE YOU?
>> THE NEXT BIG THING.
>> JUST WHAT DO YOU THINK YOU'RE
DOING?
>> CHANGING EVERYTHING.
ARE
>> INTRODUCING THE RELINE, FROM
KOEHLER, THE FIRST RECLINABLE
TANK, BRINGING LAID-BACK COMFORT
INTO THE BATHROOM FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
>> CLASS DISMISSED.
>> THERE IS ONLY ONE WAY TO SIT
ON THE TOILET.
>> KOEHLER, NUMBER ONE AND
NUMBER TWO SINCE 1873.